[Musique]
des travaux de sécurisation ont été
réalisés sur la route départementale 41
sur deux zones accidentogènes au niveau
des trois bancs dans les rampes de la
montagne mais également au niveau de la
gendarmerie sur la sécurité c'est mettre
en place au revêtement qui soit de
couleur différente qui permettent à la
tâche dès qu'ils arrivent de
s'apercevoir qu'il ya une différence et
donc d'être sensibilisés sur
l'importance de ralentir
deuxième chose c'est que les granulats
utilisé pour la résine qui sera mise sur
la route les granulats qu'elle met
devant une meilleure adhérence et donc
que ça permet d'avoir d'éviter des
glissements des véhicules sachant que
bien évidemment tout ceci est fait sous
réserve que les automobilistes d'adapter
leur vitesse à au contexte du moment la
route à boîte de belles si jamais il
peut par exemple il est évident qu'il
est important les véhicules ralentissent
à revêtement encore très soutenue qui a
déjà fait l'objet d'une expérimentation
guillaume dans l'ouest sur la route
départementale 7 et 7,1 composée de
résine du composant avec un ajout en
saupoudrage d'agrégats qui sont des
cailloux de type quoi à haute résistance
prend son courage à refus qui vont se
mêler à la résine qui vont rester en
surface non capsulée pour pouvoir
permettre en cas de pluie une adhérence
donc vous n'aurez plus de phénomène
d'aquaplaning
vous aurez toujours des cailloux qui
dépasseront des pointes qui vont
permettre aux pneus de véhicules donc de
pouvoir à dire avec une usure quand même
relativement longue parce que ce sont
des agrégats qui ont été testées avec
une dureté qui est quand même assez
important devant un balayage manuel est
ensuite effectuée à j + 1 j + 2 j + 7
enfin un balayage mécanique sera réalisé
[Musique]